I BELIEVE MAY, WHEN HE WAS IN
THE MOSCOW PRISON.
OUR SON IS INNOCENT.
>> WNBA SUPER STAR BRITTNEY
GRINER IS THE LATEST HIGH
PROFILE AMERICAN DETAINED IN
RUSSIA.
SHE WAS ARRESTED AT A MOSCOW
AIRPORT LAST MONTH AFTER
AUTHORITIES CLAIMED THEY FOUND
CANNABIS OIL DURING A SEARCH OF
HER LUGGAGE.
RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA RELEASED
THIS PHOTO TAKEN AT A POLICE
STATION SHOWING HER HOLDING A
SIGN WITH HER NAME ON IT.
HER CURRENT WHEREABOUTS ARE
UNCLEAR.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH OUR
SPORTS JOURNALIST WHO CREATED A
CAMPAIGN TO TRY TO SECURE
GRINER'S RELEASE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
MORE THAN 36,000 HAVE SIGNED ON
TO YOUR PETITION, MAKING IT ONE
OF THE FASTEST GROWING IN THE
LAST 24 HOURS.
WHAT ACTIONS ARE YOU CALLING FOR
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO
TAKE?
>> AT THIS POINT, WITH SO MUCH
GOING ON, AND AS UP, THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE BEING
SLAUGHTERED, OTHER AMERICANS
BEING HELD HOSTAGE, AND ALL THE
CURRENT THINGS HAPPENING WITH
THE INVASION, MAKING IT THAT
MUCH HARDER TO GET THEM OUT.
SO I DON'T WANT BRITTNEY GRINER
AND THE OTHER PEOPLE BEING HELD
IN RUSSIAN PRISONS TO BE LOST IN
THE NARRATIVE.
I DON'T WANT TIME TO JUST PASS
AND FOR THEM TO KIND OF FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS WITH ALL THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING DUE TO RUSSIA'S
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
>> A LOT OF VIEWERS WHO MIGHT
NOT BE FAMILIAR WITH HER STAT US
IN WOMEN'S BASKETBALL.
CAN YOU GIVE US AN IDEA OF HOW
IMPORTANT BRITTNEY IS TO THE
SPORT?
>> BRITTNEY GREINER IS AN ICON.
I WOULD CONSIDER HER DEFINITELY
ON THE COURT, SHE'S A CHAMPION.
A GOLD MEDALIST.
SHE'S WON CHAMPIONSHIPS FOR THE
TEAM SHE PLAYED FOR IN RUSSIA.
AND OFF THE COURT THOUGH, SHE
CAME OUT AS A GAY WOMAN BEFORE
EVEN SIGNING HER CONTRACT WITH
THE PHOENIX MERCURY WHERE SHE
HAS PLAYED HER ENTIRE CAREER.
AND THAT MADE A STATEMENT.
SHE, YOU KNOW, WANTED TO LIVE
AUTHENTICALLY.
SHE DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE TO HIDE
WHO SHE IS.
AND THAT HAS BEEN THE REAL GAME
CHANGER IN OUR SOCIETY.
JUST BY BEING VISIBLE, ALLOWING
HERSELF TO SAY THIS IS ME AND TO
GIVE OTHER PEOPLE PERMISSION WHO
ARE CLOSETED AND PERHAPS AFRAID
TO COME OUT, YOU KNOW, JUST A
LITTLE INSPIRATION TO LIVE THEIR
TRUTH.
AND OF COURSE, WE KNOW THAT
RUSSIA IS VERY HARD LINE
POLICIES AGAINST LGBTQ PEOPLE
AND WE ALSO SEE IN THE U.S.,
SUCH AS WHAT HAPPENED IN FLORIDA
WITH WHAT PEOPLE ARE CALLING THE
DON'T SAY GAY BILL, THESE GROUPS
THAT HAVE BEEN MARGINALIZED AND
TRADITIONALLY OPPRESSED MAKE IT
THAT MANY MORE CONCERNING THAT
SHE'S THERE.
AND WE DON'T WANT HER TO GET
LOST IN THE NARRATIVE BECAUSE OF
THAT.
>> THE WNBA SAYS ALL OTHER
PLAYERS ARE OUT OF RUSSIA.
YOU WRITE THAT THERE IS LARGELY
BEEN SILENCE FROM THE LEAGUE.
JUST ONE STATEMENT FROM HER
TEAM, THE PHOENIX MERCURY, WHAT
MORE DO YOU WANT THE WNBA AND
HER TEAM TO DO?
>> I BELIEVE TRANSPARENCY WOULD
GO A LONG WAY TO ALLEVIATING
SOME OF THE NERVES AND ANXIETY.
WHO KNOWS WHY THEY ARE BEING
SILENT?
MAYBE THEY'VE BEEN INSTRUCTED TO
BE.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
BUT NOT HAVING A NARRATIVE.
NOT COMMUNICATING WHAT IS GOING
ON LEAVES A LOT OF WORRY AND
LEAVES US TO SOME FANS, IF YOU
JUST GO ONLINE, ARE JUST AFRAID
THAT SHE'LL BE LOST.
I'VE SEEN PEOPLE WRITE, OH, THE
SEASON IS SUPPOSED TO START IN
MAY.
WE'LL JUST CARRY ON WITHOUT
BRITTNEY GRINER ON THE COURT AS
IF THAT'S OKAY?
SO IT WOULD BE GREAT IF THEY
COMMUNICATED WHAT EXACTLY
THEY'RE DOING.
AND ALSO, OTHER QUESTIONS.
WHY WAS SHE THERE AFTER THE CALL
FOR AMERICANS TO LEAVE?
WHAT ROLE DID HER RUSSIAN TEAM
PLAY IN NOT GETTING HER OUT OF
THERE SOONER?
AS WELL AS OTHER U.S. PLAYERS
WHO WERE KIND OF LATE TO RETURN
TO THE U.S.
JOHN PAUL JONES OF THE
CONNECTICUT SUN POSTED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, YOU KNOW, THAT IT WAS
JUST A TRYING TIME TO GET OUT OF
THERE AND SHE WAS IN TEARS.
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
BUT ALL OF THIS BOILS DOWN TO,
THESE WOMEN HAVE BEEN PLAYING
OVERSEAS FOR YEARS, SINCE THE
LEAGUE BEGAN BECAUSE THEY DON'T
EARN ENOUGH, NOTHING COMPARABLE
TO WHAT NBA PLAYERS EARN.
AND TH